いわし
me
rar
ああああああ
me
まじ緊張する
ええええええええええええ
re 品
かなりてった方がいいなぁ
今後に離れれば
は全然でした車
tan
me
none
しかないんだ
car
ついでのついでについてがへ待っており骨折パと戦友と下草がキター
アップツィーター
パッ
バーン
ちょっと待って
これやわでいいから
こちらです
これ沿線
いきましょうはい
というわけでん
ガースの旅
car
おいでよどこから来たか静岡スタート所
山らしいからやまなしぃうーんまもなくバカッ
浦上この中も可能村上っぽくないってんだ1的に絶えず村上でうんここに大性があるん
だよね
これ
この選考というわけで今から我々はダーツをそれということで僕がてくれ投げた
マジックの場所が村上といえばだったのでそこら辺近辺に今から向かいます
今8月の僅かなんですけどもただ冊月の僅か10度ぐらい
20aug は多分群がりにいるのですぐに来てくださいと思いませんがいいます
た
以上
あああああん
まずは東京で向かっております
持ってその下がなんでしたんだ
まだ公開されてない動画だかなまぁ後々何で東たかわかると思うんだよねそっから中で
長いと
最中で引き続きいきましょうはいというわけで今ですね8乗せまできました
入ったわけございまにつきましたけどいい動きにつきました
はいというわけで今グンマーまで来たんですけどもこのまま突っ走って
方まで行っておひでげないから多分動くよね
だろフィルいっぱいはその新潟県の村上市に入ると思いますせっかくだから何かね
新潟テーマいろいろ
美味しいものとか
e bar 村に行ったり原2-1にあたりしたいんで新潟のみんな待っててくれ
me